Guys... We're making some nice progress here.
In under 30 hours, we got almost 100,000 comments to the Copyright Office, about how the DMCA is being abused.
That is phenomenal, we cannot begin to say how thankful we are for all of this, and the great news is: It's working.
Thanks to your efforts, we have secured two spots for the U.S. Government Round Tables, talking about copyright in the future.
One in New York City on May 2nd and 3rd, and one in San Francisco on May 12th and 13th.
The Internet's voice needs to continue to be heard, and at these panels, we can at least let the government know of the abuse that's going on,
And we have you guys to thank for it.
And the other way we know it's working? We're having hit pieces put out against us!
The Copyright Alliance released a piece claiming our movement as a "zombie apocalypse".
That's right! WE'RE the zombies!
You hear that Markiplier? Jeremy Johns? PeanutButterGamer? Andy Signore? TeamFourStar? I Hate Everything?
And all the other countless people that have been making your voices heard?
You have no idea what you're talking about!
You're just mindless zombies because you voiced your opinion!
Clearly you should be supporting the people that are taking down videos without even having to see them!
But, this video is just a review-
-CLAIM!
It's protected under fair use, it's totally legal-
Won't you at least WATCH the video before you claim it-
-CLAIM!
Clearly, they're the ones that know what's going on!
And the second from the industry called what we did a "cyber attack".
I can only sum up our "nefarious plans" with this clip from a 1990s movie.
-Hack the planet!
-Hack the planet!! Hack the planet!
Yes, "hack the planet" indeed.
So now the public voicing their concerns and their opinions equals a cyberattack.
You couldn't make this up if you tried!
So, yeah, that uh... Gives you a little bit of an idea about who we're going up against and just how out of touch they are.
But this is the best kind of news you can get because it shows that we're getting to them.
Not only are they getting worried, but they're getting emotional.
Name-calling? Zombies? This is what they got right now!
But like we said before, we're in it for the long haul, and we need to keep moving forward.
Not only do we need to continue to protect fair use under the DMCA,
But make sure that this new policy from the RIAA, pushing for a new amendment of "Take Down, Stay Down", doesn't get any traction.
The recording industry wants to change the DMCA so that when one single upload gets flagged by them,
Any future piece of content using that flagged portion is automatically blocked from a site like YouTube.
So let's say, Fox blocks an upload of their newest X-Men movie on YouTube.
Does that mean any footage used for a review or anything like that is gonna be taken down? It's gonna result in your channel being destroyed?
We don't know!
It's possible it'll only affect full uploads, which they're in their right to block.
But we're giving these companies that have clearly shown they like to abuse this system even more power, and that's not good.
So, what can you do to help?
Well the cool thing is, "Fight For The Future" has decided to leave the DMCA abuse comments open until these meetings we're going to have wrapped up.
So keep sending your comments and personal stories about the DMCA abuse, and we'll make sure that it gets to the Copyright Office.
On top of that, we want to remove one of the counterpoints that the movies and recording industries keep using with no factual evidence, and we gotta prove 'em wrong on this.
They say reviews, parodies, covers, remixes, Let's Plays... Those are hurting their sales.
We know that's not true.
Me and a lot of other producers have gotten countless e-mails of people saying that they've checked out a movie or a TV show based on our material.
Or even that they completely forgot about a movie until it was reviewed.
Lets give 'em some hard numbers.
If you have ever bought a movie, video game, song, television episode or complete season, a piece of software,
Or anything else based upon someone's review, Let's Play, cover, remix, or video on YouTube, let us know.
For example, Greg Sestero, who played Mark in "The Room", he told us that our review of the movie "The Room", actually got a lot of attention on it.
And right now, he's in the process of filming a movie about that movie!
That's what happens when you get a lot of attention looking at this, it creates new media!
And it creates jobs that does all these wonderful things, and that's what we gotta get them to know.
Just click the link below and tell us what you bought and what video you saw that inspired you to purchase it.
Guys, we said from the beginning we're in it for the long haul, and it looks like you guys are too.
Honestly, this is probably just the beginning of all this, but already we're making progress.
We're making our voices heard. We are NOT gonna be quiet about this and you guys have made that possible.
And if you're just joining in to all of this, you haven't followed the "Where's The Fair Use" movement or anything like that,
there's links below to show you what we're talking about.
Copyright law is going to be changed. But with your help, we can change it for the better and protect the Internet.
Thanks everybody for your support, and this is Doug Walker still asking:
"Where's The Fair Use?".